- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday life.
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a professor of
neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, my guest is Dr. Emily Balcetis.
Dr. Balcetis is a professor of psychology
at New York University,
her laboratory studies
motivation, goal setting
and tools for successful goal completion.
I learned about Dr.
Balcetis's work some years ago
because I'm a vision scientist,
that is, I study the visual system,
and I heard about this
incredible psychologist
at New York University
who was studying how vision,
that is, how we visualize problems
can predict whether or not
we will successfully overcome challenges
and how we strategize in
order to set and meet goals.
And in 2020, I learned
of Dr. Balcetis's book,
which was written for the general public,
entitled "Clearer, Closer, Better:
How Successful People See the World".
And I read both the hard copy of the book
and listened to the audiobook,
and I absolutely loved the material.
As you'll learn directly
from Dr. Balcetis today,
how people visualize a problem,
that is, whether or not they
think of a goal or a problem
as residing at the top
of a very steep hill,
or on the top of a shallower hill,
or whether or not they
visualize a goal or a problem
as far off in the distance
or closer to them in the distance,
visually, in their mind,
strongly dictates whether
or not they will arrive
at the challenge of meeting a goal
or overcoming a problem with
more energy or less energy.
Indeed, it dictates whether or not
they can push to immediate milestones,
or whether or not they will
think they have to overcome
the entire task all at once.
Basically, Dr. Balcetis's
work has discovered
that how we visualize a
problem or a goal in our mind
has everything to do with
how we lean into that goal,
whether or not we think of it
as overwhelming or tractable,
whether or not we think that
we can overcome that goal
and then it will lead
to yet more possible rewards and goals,
or whether or not we feel
that we're going to
arrive at the finish line
and then just be overwhelmed with fatigue.
In other words, how you
visualize things in your mind,
and when I say, "Visualize,"
I mean, literally, how you visualize them
as a visual problem or a visual goal,
has everything to do
with whether or not you will
be able to meet those goals
and whether or not they will
lead to still greater goals
that you will be able to achieve.
Today's episode is an especially
important one, I believe,
because you're going to learn about
quality peer-reviewed science
from the expert in this field
of goal setting, motivation and pursuit,
and you're also going to learn
an immense number of practical tools
that you can apply toward
your educational goals,
your career goals, relationship goals,
goals of any sort.
By the end of today's episode,
you will be better equipped
to set and achieve your goals.
Dr. Balcetis also shares
with us her own experiences
of how to set, visualize
and achieve goals,
and she does that within the context
of her role as a parent,
as somebody navigating
relationships of various kinds,
and a demanding career.
So again, I think that you'll
find the information today
to be both extremely academically grounded
in terms of research,
extremely practical and realistic
in terms of how you might
apply it in your own life.
I'm pleased to announce that
the Huberman Lab Podcast
is now partnered with
Momentous supplements.
We partnered with Momentous
for several important reasons.
First of all, they ship internationally,
because we know that
many of you are located
outside of the United
States, that's valuable.
Second of all, and perhaps most important,
the quality of their
supplements is second to none,
both in terms of purity and precision
of the amounts of the ingredients.
Third, we've really emphasized supplements
that are single-ingredient supplements,
and that are supplied in dosages
that allow you to build a
supplementation protocol
that's optimized for cost,
that's optimized for effectiveness,
and that you can add things
and remove things from your protocol
in a way that's really
systematic and scientific.
This is really hard to do
if you're taking blends
of different supplements,
or if the dosages are such
that you can't titrate,
or that is, adjust the
dosages of a given supplement.
So by using single-ingredient supplements,
you can really build
out the supplement kit
that's ideal for you
and your specific needs.
If you'd like to see the supplements
that we partner with Momentous on,
you can go to livemomentous.com/huberman.
There, you'll see those supplements,
and just keep in mind
that we are constantly expanding
the library of supplements
available through Momentous
on a regular basis.
Again, that's livemomentous.com/huberman.
Before we begin, I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast
is separate from my teaching
and research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero cost to consumer
information about science
and science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics,
and as some of you have
probably heard me say before,
I am not a fan of the word nootropics
because nootropics means smart drugs,
and frankly, as a neuroscientist,
the notion of a smart drug
is somewhat ridiculous, why?
Well, it turns out that we have
neural circuits in our brain
that get engaged for creativity,
and yet other neural circuits
that are engaged for focus,
and still other neural circuits
that are engaged for task switching,
so the notion of a smart drug
or a drug that can induce
smartness, if you will,
is simply not grounded in science.
Well, Thesis understands this
and has developed custom nootropics
that are tailored to the specific
types of cognitive demands
or physical demands that
you might be facing.
If you go to Thesis's
website, you can take a quiz,
and from that, they'll give you a sample
of different nootropics that you can try
so that you can create a
customized kit of nootropics
for your specific needs.
To get your own personalized
nootropics starter kit,
just go online to takethesis.com/huberman,
take that three-minute quiz
and Thesis will send you
four different formulas
to try in your first month,
that's takethesis.com/huberman
and use the code Huberman at checkout
to get 10% off your first box.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Levels.
Levels is what's called a
continuous glucose monitor,
some of you may have
heard of these before,
others of you perhaps have not.
Basically, it's a small device
that you wear on the back of your arm,
it's an app that you
install on your phone,
and whether or not you are
fasting, or you just ate,
or you ate several hours ago,
you can get a realtime
measurement of your blood glucose,
which turns out to be
extremely informative.
I first started using
the Levels continuous glucose
monitor about a year ago,
and it's taught me so much
about how I respond to specific foods
in terms of blood sugar spikes,
how I respond to exercise,
even the sauna, it turns out,
can modulate my blood glucose levels
and your blood glucose levels
in very interesting ways.
So all of that is translated
into a huge number of very
directed changes that I've made
in terms of what I eat, when I eat,
and how I schedule
exercise relative to eating
and sleep, et cetera.
If you're interested in trying
the Levels continuous
glucose monitor yourself,
you can simply go to levels.link/huberman,
that's levels.link/huberman.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by ROKA,
ROKA makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are of the absolute highest quality,
and they also have some
unique characteristics.
The company was founded
by two All-American
swimmers from Stanford,
and everything about ROKA
eyeglasses and sunglasses
were designed with performance in mind.
ROKA eyeglasses and sunglasses
can be worn while running or cycling.
If you get sweaty, they
won't fall off your face.
And they're extremely lightweight.
In fact, most of the time,
I can't even remember
that I'm wearing them.
I wear ROKA eyeglasses
when I read at night,
so I wear their readers,
and I wear sunglasses at various
times throughout the day.
The great thing about ROKA
eyeglasses and sunglasses
is that even though they were designed
for athletic performance,
they have a terrific aesthetic.
So unlike a lot of so-called
performance glasses,
that make people look like
cyborgs, in my opinion,
ROKA eyeglasses and sunglasses
are the sort that you
could wear out to dinner,
that you could wear to work,
they have a terrific aesthetic.
If you'd like to try ROKA
eyeglasses or sunglasses,
you can go to ROKA, that's R-O-K-A, .com,
and enter the code Huberman
to save 20% off your first order.
Again, that's ROKA, that's R-O-K-A, .com,
and enter the code Huberman at checkout.
And now for my discussion
with Dr. Emily Balcetis.
Well, thanks for being here.
- It's my pleasure.
- Yeah, I've been looking
forward to this for a long time,
because as a vision scientist,
who is also very interested
in real-life tools
and goal setting and motivation,
your work lands squarely in
the middle of those interests.
So just to kick things off,
could you tell us just a little
bit about the relationship
between perception,
and in particular, how we see the world,
and goal setting and goal retrieval.
It's a vast landscape,
but you're the expert,
so I'll turn that over to you.
[Emily laughing]
And then, as time goes on,
I may have some additional questions
as it relates to
different kinds of vision,
but what's the deal with
vision and motivation?
How do those two things link up?
- Yeah, totally, I mean, when
psychologists ask people,
like, "What are you doing
to help make progress on your goals?"
they say all kinds of things,
but a couple things always pop to the top,
which is, "Try to shock
myself in encouraging ways,
and self-pep talks,"
or, "I remind myself of how
important it is to do this job,"
or, "I'll put up Post-it notes around
to constantly be nagging me
about what I need to do."
So those are common
tactics that people use,
and what we'll notice is that
those are really effortful,
having to constantly remind yourself,
having to constantly talk to yourself,
having to create those Post-it notes,
remember to look at them,
all of that takes a lot of
time and effort and commitment,
and so what a surprise that
people burn out, right?
It's exciting to work on a
goal when you first set it,
you might make some initial progress,
but then eventually we get
not even to the halfway point
before things get real, [laughing]
things are challenging,
and we fall by the wayside.
And that's, I think, because those tactics
that are our go-to strategies
are themselves a goal to maintain.
So it's double sided, we're
putting so much on ourselves
to try to advance the thing
that we originally set out to accomplish.
So then, with my team, I
was trying to think of,
like, "Well, what are strategies
that don't require as much effort,
that we can automate,
that we can take advantage
of what's already happening
within ourselves, within
our body, within our mind,
that might overcome one
of those challenges,
that'll be easier, more automated?"
And that's when we started to land
on the idea of vision, right?
We look at the world
without even thinking of it,
for those of us that are sighted,
and we thought, "You know what?
There are strategies that we can use
to look at the world in a different way
and that we can automate
that might help us to
overcome some obstacles,
to make progress on our goals,
to maybe literally see opportunities
that we hadn't been able to see before."
So we started playing around
with the idea of visual illusions to see,
like, "Do people even know
that there's other ways of
seeing things around them?
Can we tweak that, or is
there room for intervention?
Can we encourage people to
take a new way of looking
to see things that they
hadn't seen before?"
And that's what really opened us up
to trying to look at that intersection
between vision science
and motivation science.
- That's great, and I always say,
and here, I'm strongly
biased as a vision scientist,
that vision is the dominant sense
by which we navigate
the world and survive.
I love this idea of real-world,
realtime access to vision.
And I'm certainly familiar
with how goal setting or Post-its
and magnets on refrigerators
can have an immediate
impact, but then over time,
they become so part of
the visual landscape
that you overlook them,
and we know, as vision scientists,
if something is stably
in your environment,
eventually, you're blind to it,
so that makes good sense.
So you've published a number
of studies in this area,
but maybe you could
highlight some of the more,
what you would consider important findings
in the area of how people
can adjust their vision
in order to meet goals more
quickly and more efficiently,
and perhaps also how
we all arrive at goals
with different visual perceptions,
and that, in some way,
may divide us into highly motivated
and less motivated people,
in other words, what's the link
between vision and motivation,
and how can we leverage that
in order to better reach our goals?
- Totally, so we started thinking about,
"What are the goals that
are most important to people
that they struggle with the most?"
So we asked hundreds, thousands of people
what their new year's resolutions are,
we looked to all the other polls
that do the same kind of work,
and regardless of where you look,
or who you ask, or when you ask it,
people's number-one goal
is something related
to their health, right?
To lose weight, to exercise more,
to get out, get more steps,
for mental wellbeing, physical wellbeing.
And that's like the number-one
goal every January 1st.
So if we were able to
accomplish that goal,
you'd think it would drop
[laughing] a little bit in the rankings,
but it doesn't because it's really hard.
So we thought, "I wonder if there's a way
for us to make some progress on that,
on helping people to exercise better,
more often, stick to it longer,
and make some progress there?"
We know diets don't work. [laughing]
Why don't diets work?
For the same reason that
that self-talk doesn't work,
is that we go in it, full bore, hardcore,
and it requires a major
commitment and effort
to a lifestyle change.
So again, we were looking for something
that might be easier than that,
that could produce big payoff, right?
That's the golden ticket, [laughing]
is something that requires less
effort for a bigger payoff.
So one of the first things that I did
was go over to Brooklyn,
to this old armory building,
it used to be a military
armory space, yeah.
- I think I know that building.
- Yeah, it's beautiful.
- It's a beautiful building,
now, that houses a lot
of businesses, right?
With plants on the walls,
is that the one?
- Yeah, there's businesses,
there's a couple of armories
all around the boroughs
here around New York City,
and the one in Brooklyn in
particular is now YMCA, right?
So it's a family YMCA,
that's within this beautiful
old redbrick building
that used to be a military
establishment long, long ago.
And what's really cool is
that, one winter afternoon,
somebody had invited me,
a physical therapist said,
"Hey, you should come out
and check out what's happening here,
with your interest in exercise
and trying to find new
ways of helping people,
new tactics that they can
add to their tool belt,
I think you're going to
find some interesting people
that are working out there."
So I showed up, I look around,
there's families, there's
new moms, there's kids,
moms trying to get kids to burn off
some winter energy that they have,
there's people that look like
they're just there for their,
every couple of days, going out for a run.
There's some people that look like
they're training with a team,
and that's who this physical
therapist introduced me to,
was the coach of this team.
There's a bunch of people
that were sitting down
on the ground,
and I would be hard pressed
to know who is the high school student
that's in this group,
and then who, as it turns out,
are some of the fastest
runners in the world.
One of the people that
was in the last Olympics
before I showed up, won the
gold medal for the 400 meter.
And from the looks of them,
I mean, of course,
their bodies are in
better shape than mine,
but there's nothing so,
of course, they're not
wearing their medals,
there's nothing pretentious
about how they're walking
around or anything like that,
that would lead me to know,
like, "This person's amazing,
and they probably have some
insight that I don't have."
So once I got introduced to them
and knew who are these people
that were part of this
pretty elite training team
that happened to work
out at this family gym,
I had the chance to talk with them about,
"What strategies do you use?"
Now, I am not an elite runner,
and having recently had a baby,
I'm not really a runner right now at all,
but I thought, "When
these people are running,
I bet they are hyper aware
of everything that's going
on in their surroundings.
Where are they relative
to the competition,
what's happening in
their peripheral vision,
what's going on on the side,
who's behind them, who's in front of them?
They probably have this master sense,
this master visual plan
at any point in time,
and that's what probably
makes them elite."
So when I started asking
them, "Is that the case,
do you really pay attention to
what's in your surroundings,
what's behind you, what's on the side?"
They said, "No,"
all of them said, "No, and
sometimes when I do do that,
it's a mistake, it doesn't work for me."
So that was surprising
and totally went against my
intuition about what they do
that likely contributes to their success.
What they said instead was
that they are hyper focused,
they assume this narrowed
focus of attention,
almost like a spotlight
is shining on a target.
Now, when they're
running a short distance,
that target might literally
be the finish line,
the line that they're trying to cross.
If it's a longer distance,
they set subgoals,
like the person, the shorts
on the person up ahead
that they're trying to beat,
or they choose some
sort of stable landmark,
like a sign that they would pass by.
And a spotlight is shining just on that,
or they have blinders on
the sides of their face,
that's all they're paying attention to,
this really narrowed scope of attention.
And that was a strategy that
all of these elite athletes
said that they used,
and those that were
better rather than slower
were ones that used it more.
And I thought, "Oh, that's something
we can play with, right?
They are elite [laughing]
and they are accomplished,
but that visual strategy
isn't necessarily something
that you have to be in the
perfect physical condition
to be able to adopt,
and so I wonder, can
that help the rest of us
who aren't competing for an Olympic gold
and who have no chance
of ever getting one,
but who want to exercise better,
have a better time doing it,
and maintain a commitment
to that exercise goal
that they might have,
that they might otherwise,
by February or March, be giving up on,
if they had said it at
the beginning of January?"
So that's really where the work started,
was what you might call focus groups
or case studies [laughing]
of these incredible athletes.
And then we did other studies,
looking at people who
aren't Olympic athletes,
but who are competitive and
New York Road Runners runners,
and how are they running in races?
And what we found is that those people
who have better pace,
faster pace, better time,
they use that narrowed strategy
more often than this more expansive
or open scope of attention.
And there seemed to be a correlation
between that better performance
among a wider swath of
hundreds of runners,
who are doing it competitively,
but still, could be like the person
that you're sitting next to in the office,
or yourself, right?
And the more often that they did it
and the more consistently
they had adopted that,
that technique of the
narrowed focus of attention,
it seemed that they were
doing better in their runs.
So then we started thinking like,
"Okay, what about people who
aren't competitive runners?
What about like my mom,
[laughing] can she do that,
or me when I'm trying to
get back on the bandwagon
and exercise more,
is this a tactic we can teach people?"
The answer is yes, you can tell people
about what these Olympic
athletes are doing,
you can tell them about
what the New York Road
Runners runners are doing,
and just using the same language
that I just used with you, right?
"Imagine that there's a spotlight
shining just on a target,
choose something up ahead,
the stop sign two blocks
up that you can just see,
and imagine that you have blinders on
so that you're not really paying attention
to the people that are passing by,
or the buildings, or the garbage cans,
or the trucks that are on the road,
tune those out and
focus in on that target,
until you hit it, and then
choose another one, right?
Sort of recalibrate,
choose the next goal."
And so we would test,
like, "Can people do that?"
I mean, if you're listening right now,
you probably are imagining
that experience too,
and the answer is yes,
like, "I can imagine that, I
know what those words mean,
and I can do that."
And our work found that too,
that people can do that,
we have them say out loud,
"What is it that's
captured your attention?"
And of course, "Sometimes
something in the periphery,
like movement, captures our gaze
and we are pulled there for an instant,
but then we can refocus up again
and adopt that narrowed attention."
Now, one of the first studies that we did
was teach that strategy
and juxtapose or compare it
against a group that we said,
"Just look around naturally,
you might see that finish line up ahead
and there's things on the periphery,
whatever your eyes want to do,
whatever you think is going to work best,
feel free to do that, and tell
us what you're looking at."
Then we gave them a finish line,
we created sort of an exercise
that's moderately
challenging, but possible.
We put ankle weights on
that accounted for about
15% of their body weight,
told them to lift their knees up,
sort of high stepping to a finish line.
So this would be
challenging for them to do,
but we said, "It's an indicator
of overall health and fitness."
Some of these people had
narrowed their focus of attention
and some were just looking
more expansively or naturally.
And what we found is that
those people that we trained,
just everyday normal people
doing this moderately
challenging exercise,
they were able to move 27% faster.
They could do the exercise more quickly,
and they said it hurt 17% less.
The exercise was exactly the
same for all of the people,
we set the weight, [laughing]
we set the distance,
it was in our lab space,
so it was a constrained environment,
everybody was in the same
sort of circumstance,
but yet their experience
was really different,
we helped them to move faster,
burn calories at a higher rate, right?
Exercise more efficiently,
the amount of time they put in
is going to produce a
better physical outcome,
and also, it didn't hurt them, right?
They're saying, "It doesn't hurt as much."
So we were really excited
about that, right?
Because it meant that this strategy,
we could use it on people
who were not elite athletes.
It could be easily adopted,
a quick training session, right,
can teach people to look at
the world in a different way.
Again, this narrowed
attention was different
than whatever they do
naturally, the comparison group,
but it had a big outcome,
it had a big difference on the way
that they were engaged in the exercise.
It was some of the first work that we did,
and then, since then,
we've done, I don't know,
dozens more studies to look at,
"Well, what happens with that
and what else can we do with
playing around with this?"
- Yeah, those are impressive differences
as a consequence of
narrowing visual attention.
Couple of questions
about the actual practice
of narrowing attention,
is there any indication
of whether or not subjects
are constantly updating
their visual attention?
So for instance, if let's
say the goal line is in view,
literally, from the beginning,
I could imagine just
holding visual attention
on the goal line,
but if it's a oval track,
or it's a trajectory along
a trail, or through a city,
how often do you think they are updating
their visual aperture and
setting a visual goal?
And I could imagine
that there's some
energetic expense to that,
so meaning, you wouldn't want to do
every crack on the sidewalk,
unless those cracks on the sidewalk
were very far apart.
- [laughing] Right.
- Because I think, at some point,
that itself would be exhausting.
So is there an optimal strategy
or a semi-optimal strategy?
- Yeah, so those Olympic athletes
that we started by interviewing,
they tended to be sprinters,
they were more often sprinters,
short-distance sprinters.
So when they said like, "Yes, I narrow in
more than I assume an expansive focus,"
that's because they're
not going that far, right?
They have to do it as
fast as humanly possible,
but they're not going that far.
And so we started asking
that question too,
about, like, "Well,
wouldn't that be tiring?"
And the answer is yes,
so when we start to look at,
well, people who aren't sprinters,
who are accomplished,
but who are more long-distance runners,
that's what we find that they do,
is that they're using
that narrowed attention
strategy strategically,
and it increases in use,
they use it more often
as the race progresses,
and they really start to do
this major switch [laughing]
at about the halfway point of
say like a 10-kilometer run.
So people who are seasoned runners,
they really start making a switch
with what they're looking
at about halfway through,
and that's where they more
often, more frequently
and are more intentionally adopting
a narrowed focus of attention
when they're in the last
couple miles of a run,
when maybe their resources
are starting to get more thin,
maybe their motivation
is starting to fade.
That tipping point in the middle is,
with any kind of goal, where
people struggle the most,
and that's when they're doubling down
on a strategy that they
know to be effective.
So at first, longer-distance runners
are not using that narrowed strategy,
they're looking more expansively,
because I think that that,
well, first of all, distraction
[laughing] is a thing,
it's useful.
Not necessarily that they're
distracting themselves,
because people are still
trying to hold pace and jostle
among probably a more
concentrated group of runners,
but it is a strategy that they use,
and then sort of wean off
of as the race goes through.
And it's particularly effective
when we're looking for
that last push, right?
The last push to get over the finish line,
when you might be literally
neck and neck with somebody
that you're trying to just beat out,
or when you're most tired,
but you know that last push,
you don't want to drop off,
and when you want to push through hard
through that finish
line, that's when people
are using it at its
peak level of intensity.
- I see, yeah.
To me, this makes total
sense why it would work,
without going down the rabbit
hole of visual neuroscience,
something for another time,
that when we do these
vergence eye movements,
when we bring our eyes to a visual target,
it's clear that some of
the brainstem circuitry
for alertness gets engaged
to a greater degree.
The other thing is that we know
that when we focus on an object,
that the optics of the eye change
and narrow the visual field.
So that brings about, this
is a very detailed question,
but I'm sure the audience is wondering,
if let's say I'm focused on a goal line
or an intermediate goal,
are they focusing on a specific point
or is it kind of the entire
horizon of that goal?
Because the finish line is indeed a line.
And of course, it's impossible to know
what someone is actually
doing in their mind's eye,
but how do people report this?
Do they see it literally as a spotlight?
And if so, how broad is that spot?
- Yeah, so what is the length [laughing]
of their aperture rather
than maybe the diameter
or the sphere size of it?
In our interviews with people,
our sort of focus group studies,
it seems like it's more
like a circular point.
And that's in fact what
we're teaching people,
what we're training them to do,
so rather than going broadly,
looking across a line from left to right,
we are encouraging them to
imagine a circle of light
that's shining on some target.
Now, of course, a finish line is a line,
but if they're staying in their lane,
if they're on a track, right?
You can imagine that
there is a circle shining
just on where in their lane
they'll cross that finish line,
or if it's a stop sign,
you could imagine a circle
of light illuminating that.
So that's what we're
teaching people to use
and that's what seems to be effective
to maintain that focus
rather than sort of being pulled
to engage with peripheral vision.
And there's some amazing people,
some runners in history,
like Joan Benoit Samuelson,
she's one of the first
female marathon competitors,
who has won multiple marathons.
She's Canadian, I think she's won,
feel free to correct me, like
10 marathons in her life.
And she talks about sort of not assuming
this wide but narrow, [laughing]
wide but not deep or
tall attentional focus.
She talks about, like, "Finding the shorts
on somebody ahead of me
and focusing on those shorts,"
until she passes them, and
then resetting that goal.
So in her interviews that she's
done with runners magazines,
she talks about it in terms
of this circle of attention.
- Mm, I think I've
experienced this a little bit,
because we're visiting New
York now to do this interview,
and runners here seem more competitive,
recreational runners here
seem more competitive.
People walking on the
street seem competitive.
- Yeah. [laughing]
- You're walking at near pace
to somebody, they'll quickly speed up.
If you speed up, they'll speed up.
- Yeah.
- I think there have been
some studies about walking
speed in different cities,
and New York ranks among
the fastest walkers around.
I won't mention the
slowest-walking cities.
[Emily laughing]
'Cause we don't want to
cast any judgments.
But fascinating, and
again, makes total sense
based on the way that the visual system
measures both space and time.
- Yeah.
- Something maybe we'll get
into a little bit later,
but I'm curious whether
or not the whole thing
works in reverse as well.
Meaning, do people who are
very motivated to exercise,
do they think this way naturally?
People who are averse to exercise
or who find it hard to
get motivated to exercise,
do they view the world differently,
literally?
- Yeah,
yeah, I have so much that
I can say about this,
so [laughing] if you'll humor me,
I'll give you a couple
different stories about
how we can answer that.
- Please.
- So you don't have to do a
deep dive into vision science,
which, of course, you
are capable of doing,
but what I can share with you
is some animal studies where this work
kind of first started.
This is in the 1940s, 1950s,
rat labs, mice labs.
And they were looking,
those were the first
models of human behavior
that people were trying
to understand motivation,
motivation science within.
So they would deprive
these poor rats and mice
of food or water,
so that they were motivated
to get it. [laughing]
They were hungry and they were thirsty
and they had practice running a maze
so they knew where they could
find that food or water,
whatever that they were looking for.
And what these researchers were studying
was the pace of movement through the maze.
So as the rats were
going through the maze,
they found that even though
these rats were hungry
and they're having to expend
limited caloric energy
to make it to the finish
line, they actually ran faster
the closer they got to that finish line.
So once that finish line
became nearer to them,
they actually used their resources,
probably suboptimally,
to make sure that they
crossed the finish line
and got their reward.
So that was some of the first early work
that was showing that proximity to a goal
increases the investment
in resources that people,
that animals use to meet that goal,
even when they don't have that much spare.
And with the mice, the same kind of thing,
they actually had these
little harnesses on them,
they were looking at how
hard do the mice pull
to try to make it to the food or the water
that they were trying to get.
And same deal, the closer they
got to getting their reward,
the harder they were pulling,
even though they didn't have
that much energy to spare
and they had already used some up
getting to that finish line.
So that early animal research
from the 1940s, 1950s,
then spurred a whole
wave of work in humans.
Do humans do the same thing?
Even when they're tired, but they can see
or they can feel that their goal is close,
do they double down and work even harder
to cross that finish line,
either a literal finish line,
if we're talking about exercise,
or a metaphorical finish line
if we're talking about
any other kind of goal
that people might have?
And the answer is yes,
they called that the
goal gradient hypothesis,
the closer you get to the goal,
generally, the harder
people and animals work
to finish that goal.
That's what led us then to think,
"Okay, those rats, those mice,
those people are seeing
a finish line, right?
And it's when they're maybe
seeing that finish line,
seeing that reward, seeing the goal
they're hoping to accomplish,
that is what's leading them to try harder,
to invest more so that
they can finish it off.
What if we induce that
illusion of proximity?
What if we can induce a visual illusion,
a visual experience that approximates
what the real rats and mice
were actually experiencing
as they got closer?"
So that is what is happening,
that's what's happening visually
when we create that
narrowed focus of attention,
when we tell people,
"Imagine there's a spotlight
on the shorts of the person up ahead,
or the stop sign that you're seeing,"
it induces an illusion of proximity
that then is responsible
for people trying harder,
walking faster, or feeling that
it defied their expectations
and that it wasn't as bad
as they thought it would be.
So we do things like measure,
like measure their visual experience,
like, "How far away is that finish line?"
Of course, we can ask
them to report in feet,
"How many feet is it?"
Ah, but that's challenging, right?
Nobody really knows what three feet
versus four feet really looks like,
but they do, so we can ask
them how many feet it is.
We also use these other measures of,
like visual matching measures
to know that distance to the finish line
looks about as far away
as this other target,
their matching up their
visual experiences.
So what we know is that inducing
that narrowed focus of attention
is creating an illusion of proximity,
that goal looks closer to them.
And then there's all kinds of downstream,
motivational and psychological
effects that happen
from feeling like you're closer,
by visually misperceiving that space,
it can have a really positive consequence.
So your first question
was, "Which way does it go?
Does it go both ways,
that people who are better runners
happen to do this thing?"
Yes, some of our research shows that,
that if they, for whatever reason,
happened upon this strategy
and continued to practice it,
they tended to be the better runners.
But we also know from our
experiments in the lab,
where we take people who don't
know about these strategies,
and by a flip of the coin,
we randomly assign them
to either learn the strategy and use it
or do whatever comes naturally to them,
we can create that illusion of proximity,
that has a direct and causal impact
on improving their performance
when they're exercising.
So yes, it goes both ways,
but you can also teach yourself
that you don't have to just rely on luck,
luck of the draw for being a person
who happens to be better at exercising
or whose eyes happen to
do this on their own.
- Before we continue
with today's discussion,
we're going to take a brief pause
to acknowledge our
sponsor, Athletic Greens,
also called AG1.
I started taking Athletic
Greens way back in 2012,
so I'm delighted that they've been
a sponsor of this podcast.
Athletic Greens contains
vitamins, minerals, probiotics,
digestive enzymes
[laughing] and adaptogens,
so it's got a lot of things in there,
and that's actually the
reason I started taking it,
and the reason I still take
it once or twice a day.
It essentially covers all
of my nutritional bases,
and the probiotics in
particular are important to me
because of the critical importance
of what's called the gut-brain access,
that is neurons and other
cell types in the gut,
in the digestive tract,
that communicate with the brain
and the brain back to the digestive tract
in order to control things like mood,
immune function, hormone
function, and on and on.
Whenever somebody has asked me
what's the one supplement
they should take?
I always answer, "Athletic Greens."
I gave that answer long
before I ever had this podcast
and it's the answer I still give now,
for all the reasons that I
detailed just a moment ago.
If you'd like to try Athletic Greens,
you can go to athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim a special offer.
They'll give you five free travel packs
that make it really easy
to mix up Athletic Greens
while you're on the road,
plus a year's supply of vitamin D3K2,
which are also very important
for a huge number of bodily
factors and brain factors
that impact your immediate
and long-term health.
Again, that's athleticgreens.com/huberman
to claim that special offer.
The most pressing question
I have in my mind is,
can we, I, all of us,
use this strategy to make the
starting line a goal point?
Because for a lot of people,
it's not about going from start to finish,
it's about getting to start.
And I would say, here, I'm estimating,
but 15% of the content on social media
is about motivation and how
to get motivated to do things.
Neurochemicals like dopamine, of course,
being at the heart of motivation.
In my mind, I'm making strong links
between some of these
visual aperture effects
and goal lines and dopamine
that we could also dive into.
But the simple question is,
can I use this finish line strategy
to make the start line a goal
and get my system more
engaged or motivated?
And is there any physiology,
or physiological changes, I should say,
to reflect the idea
that maybe just visually
focusing on the start line
would actually get me more excited
as opposed to make me less
excited to engage in effort?
- Mm-hmm, there's certainly vision science
that's tied up in that very
first stage of goal setting,
like identifying what that
goal is in the first place
and taking those first steps.
A lot of people's go-to
strategies that involve vision
are vision boards, or dream
boards, or Post-it notes, right?
They're creating some sort
of visual representation
of what it is that they
want to accomplish,
"Where is it that I want
to be in five years,
10 days, 10 years?"
Whatever that timeline is
that they're working under.
The idea of vision boards or dream boards
is that you, almost like
a scrapbook, [laughing]
collect visual icons that
reflect where you want to be
to motivate yourself.
It's a really common
tactic that people use,
and it's not bad to do that, right?
For some people, just even
knowing what they want in life
is a major accomplishment,
defining the goal can be
really challenging for people,
and that's a strategy that works
and involves our visual experience, right?
It's not just, people aren't saying like,
"Why don't you just sit around and imagine
what you want your life
to be like in 10 years?"
The strategy that people
are suggesting is like,
"No, cut out the pictures,
put it on a board and stick
it by your bathroom mirror
so you see it every day,"
right?
- Or make a list.
- Or make a list, yeah.
- People are big
on these lists, I have a lot of friends
that are like, "Have you made your list?"
The list of things that
you insist on having
in the context of fitness,
relationship, job,
et cetera, et cetera,
this seems more and more
common now, yeah.
- Yeah, totally, and the idea,
like, "Write it down," right?
They're telling you, "Write it down,"
or, "Create a visual manifestation of it."
And so yeah, that's effective
for identifying what you want,
but it may not actually be effective
for helping you to meet the goal,
to get the job done.
So colleagues of mine
at New York University
have probed, "Well, why, why is that?
Why is just thinking about
what you want in your life
and sort of putting yourself
vicariously into those shoes,
imagining what my life will be like
if I can accomplish
everything on this list,
why doesn't that work?"
Well, first of all, "Does it work?"
The answer is no, "And
why does it not work?"
Because what happens,
these colleagues, Gabriele Oettingen
and her research team have found
is that going through and dreaming about
or, "Visualizing how great my life will be
when I get X, Y and Z done,"
that is like a goal satisfied.
"I have identified what it is that I want,
I have experienced it, even
if just in an imaginary way,
I've had that positive
experience of thinking about,
well, how great my life is going to be
when I get this thing done,"
and they start to sort
of rest on their laurels.
She's actually measured
systolic blood pressure
and heart rate,
and they found that people who do that,
who go through that experience of,
"Visualizing how great my life will be
when I get X, Y and Z done,"
their systolic blood pressure,
the bottom number on your blood
pressure reading, decreases.
Okay, now, I'm all about
finding ways to relax,
especially in New York, right?
You're constantly living at
a high level of stimulation,
and so like, "Cool, great,
so maybe I should just think about
how awesome my life will be
when I get my bucket list done,"
but motivation scientists know
that systolic blood pressure
is actually an indicator
of our body's readiness
to get up and act, to do something.
Now, that can be the going out for a walk,
going out for a run, hitting the gym,
it can also be things
like doing math problems,
[laughing] right?
Even if it's something that's just mental,
systolic blood pressure actually goes up
in anticipation of your body or your mind
needing to do something,
taking the first steps on a goal.
So then it helps us to understand of like,
"Okay, if I've just
created this dream board,
this vision board, and
put myself psychologically
in that space of a goal satisfied,
why is it bad that blood
pressure goes down?"
Because it means your
body is chilling out,
it's like, "All right, cool,
I just accomplished something
pretty major," right?
"I actually now don't have
the physiological resources
at the ready to take
the first step right now
to do something about that."
So that was a pretty monumental finding
for motivation scientists,
to understand that creating
these dream boards,
these vision boards, or to-do lists,
might actually backfire,
because it in and of itself
is the creation of a goal and
the satisfaction of the goal,
and then people
understandably give themselves
some time to just enjoy
that positive experience.
- So much for "The Secret".
- [Emily] Yeah, exactly,
[laughing] exactly.
- I guess now "The Secret"
folks will come after me
with pitchforks, but.
- I try to never
say the name, [laughing] right?
For that reason.
- Well, I'm not afraid
to say the name, I mean,
I imagine that certain strategies
might work for other people,
but everything you're saying, again,
is consistent with what we know
about the physiology of dopamine
circuits for motivation.
I have a good friend who perhaps
incidentally, perhaps not,
is a cardiologist at a major university,
said that one of the major
errors that people make
with book writing and completion
is they will tell people
they're going to write a book
and people will say,
"Oh, you definitely should write a book,
everyone's going to love your book,"
and they never end up writing it.
And his theory is that they
get so much dopamine reward
from that immediate feedback,
with all the protection of never
having the book criticized,
that they never write the book.
I'm sure there are exceptions to this,
but I guess it raises the question,
what's the better strategy?
- Yeah, so I'm not saying
that people who enjoy dream board creation
should stop what they're doing,
that's not the take-home message here.
- Nightmare board.
- [laughing] Oh,
definitely not that, no.
- Okay, okay.
- There's enough anxiety
and fear in the world,
we don't need to encourage more of it.
But the process of goal setting
shouldn't stop with
articulating what the goal is.
So at that same point that
we're trying to figure out,
"What do we want to do,
what is my vision for the future?"
in those planning sessions,
we need to simultaneously think about
a couple of other things.
One is how are we going to get there?
So take it out of the abstract,
take it out of this
idyllic visual iconography
and start thinking about
the practical day to day.
We need to break it down
into more manageable goals,
not just, "My 10-year plan for myself,"
but, "My two-week plan,
what can I accomplish
in the next two weeks
and the two weeks after
that's going to set me
on the right trajectory?"
That's probably not surprising
to anybody [laughing]
who's been thinking about,
"How do I set goals better?"
Plan big picture, think
big picture abstractly,
but then also break it
down more concretely,
that's probably not surprising,
but it's an important aspect
of the goal setting process.
Then, again, Gabriele
Oettingen in my department
has identified a third often overlooked
or underappreciated
stage that has to happen
in the goal setting process,
and that's thinking about the obstacles
that stand in your way of success,
and that, it will actually
help improve motivation
in the long run.
And sometimes people think
that that is counterintuitive,
"You're saying if I want
to increase my motivation,
have more motivation,
then I need to think about
how hard it's going to be,
all the ways that I'm going to fail?
How is that going to jazz me up?
How's that going to help me get
through when things get hard?"
But it does because it's
like coming up with a plan B,
a plan C, plan D,
in advance of actually experiencing that.
If you were on a boat and
the boat started to sink,
that's not the time
you want to start
looking for life jackets.
You already want to know where one is
so you can go to it right away.
And it's the same thing with goal setting,
is that you want to know,
"What am I working towards?
How am I going to get there?
And if I experience this obstacle,
here's what I'm going to do about it."
You may never experience that obstacle,
but if you do, you're probably
going to be shy on time,
thin on resources,
maybe experiencing an anxiety
that hijacks your brain
so you're not functioning
at that optimal level of
judgment and decision making.
You want to already have
the snap next step in place
so you can just hop to it, right?
We're not going to do our best thinking
when we're in crisis mode,
but we don't have to
if we have already used
our resources in advance to come up with
that plan B or that plan C.
Michael Phelps, incredible athlete, right?
This is something that he and his coach
have routinely incorporated
into their training.
So I love this story that, back in 2008,
he was hot for the first time
on the international stage.
It was the Beijing Olympics,
Michael Phelps was on the
brink of doing something
that no one else in the
history of the Olympic Games
has ever done,
which was win eight gold
medals in a single Olympiad.
At the time of this story,
he had already won seven
and he had just the
200 fly in front of him
before he could do what
no one else has ever done,
win the eighth gold medal.
And the fly is his thing, right?
This should've been easy, a no-brainer,
he's going to win this, he's
going to break Olympic history.
As soon as he dove into the pool,
his goggles started to leak.
And by the time he had done
three lengths of the pool,
he just had to flip around
and come back to the starting
line slash finish line,
back to the edge.
By the time that happened,
his goggles were completely
filled with water
and he was swimming blind.
I would've panicked,
I would've sunk to the bottom of the pool,
I wouldn't have even been
in the pool to be honest,
I'm not a swimmer, definitely
not going to be in the Olympics,
but for him, he didn't, it
wasn't a moment of panic,
like it probably would've been
for nearly every other
person in that situation,
because he had foreshadowed
that kind of possible failure.
He had imagined that obstacle
hitting him in advance,
and not even just imagined
it, but practiced it,
"What will we do?"
He routinely practiced
swimming with his goggles
not fully secured on his face,
his coach notoriously would rip
the goggles off of his head,
smash 'em on the ground
for maybe dramatic effect or something,
so that he didn't even have any goggles
possible to grab as he's in practice.
So because he had
foreshadowed that possibility
and the solution, "If my
goggles start to leak,
then I will do," in his case,
"start counting my strokes,
then I'll make it through."
He knew exactly how many
strokes it would take from him
to get from one end of
the pool to the other,
he started counting his strokes.
He won that race, the 200 fly,
he won his eighth gold medal
and he'd go on to win
15 more in his career.
So we might not all be swimmers,
we might not all aspire to
Olympic-level performance,
but I love that example
because I think it helps sort of demystify
or give us an alternative
perspective on the importance
and the motivational reasons
why thinking about obstacles in advance,
thinking about the ways,
the two, three, four ways
that your plan might go awry
is actually effective at helping
us to overcome the obstacle
that might otherwise lead
us to throw in the towel.
- That's a beautiful example.
I'm going to springboard off that example
to ask a question that
has also been on my mind,
which is, is there really
anything special about vision?
Because in the example you just gave,
it was indeed vision that
Michael Phelps was deprived of
and it was counting strokes.
Counting is another form
of incremental measurement,
in the nervous system, obviously.
There are others, they
could be the sensation
of the hands smacking the water
or breaking the surface of the water,
so there are any number
of different variables
or metrics that one could use.
I could imagine that setting out on a,
let's say, a three-mile run,
which, for me, is a decent-distanced run,
it's one I do a few times a week,
I'm also not a runner,
but I try and complete some
runs a few times a week,
at very slow pace,
just for my health.
[Emily laughing]
I could count every step,
that would be kind of exhausting,
but if I knew that three miles was,
I'm going to estimate here, I don't know,
a couple thousand steps,
I could count backward,
I could count forward,
I could count every 10.
I confess, I spend every morning
trying to find sunlight
to get sun in my eyes
to set my circadian rhythm,
and I do 100 jumping jacks.
So I'm the guy that people
are looking at strange on the street.
[Emily laughing]
But sometimes I count
every 10, sometimes I count backwards,
sometimes I count forward.
Is there any indication that it matters
or is it simply that we
attach some sort of meaning
to that increment and the mode
of reaching that increment?
Because it does seem like
there's something special about vision,
and we could maybe dive into
a little bit more why that is,
but at a very basic level,
how broadly or finally should
one set the increments,
and does it matter if
you're counting steps
or counting strokes,
maybe it's every other song,
you're going to listen to an entire album.
That's something that I don't
know if people do anymore.
[Emily laughing]
Or you're going to listen
to a whole playlist,
and then listen to it again,
and you're going to run
as long as the playlist
is completed twice,
you can obviously see what I'm getting at,
but I know people are going to
want to implement these tools.
And I have to guess
that the nervous system
is somewhat indiscriminent
when it comes to these things,
but that there might
also be some specificity.
- I think vision is special,
and I think you do too,
and for a variety of reasons.
When you start, you can really nerd out
on how cool the brain is
and how cool vision is within the brain.
And when you do, then you
start to find some things
that make vision unique, right?
More real estate, more
neurological cortex real estate
is taken up by the visual
sense than any other sense,
more than taste, touch, smell, right?
Vision gets more real estate,
gets more neurological processing space
than any other sense, why is that?
Well, because evolution has led us
to prioritize the visual experience.
There's some cool illusions
where maybe somebody's mouth
is doing something different
than what you're hearing,
when people sort of
create these weird tricks
that might go on YouTube and go viral,
and people are trying to
figure out, "What did I hear?
What did I see his mouth doing?"
And what comes up is
that people prioritize
what they see over what they're hearing
when the two are incompatible
or kind of out of sync.
- Every time.
- Yeah, every time, right?
If you have to bet on it,
bet on what it is that you're looking at
rather than what you're seeing.
And why is that?
Well, [sighing] I guess, a
couple other things too, right?
We can see super far, you
can see a flickering candle
on a horizon if it was a totally clear sky
several miles away.
You can see the
International Space Station
floating up in the night sky, right?
Hundreds of miles away,
our eyes are amazing.
And we prioritize what we see,
and I think that's because we never,
we rarely [laughing] get the experience
of having our visual
experience second guessed.
Oftentimes, we're having a conversation
maybe in a loud restaurant
and we know that we didn't
hear the person, right?
And so we say like,
"Oh, did you say that?"
Or like, "Oh, I thought you said this,"
and they're like, "No, I
didn't say that," right?
So people will correct us
when our ears get it wrong,
or we're tasting something amazing
and we can't quite figure
out what spices were in here,
and so we know that our tongue
isn't quite picking up
the taste the right way,
and that's why we read the menu
to see what are the
ingredients or we ask the chef,
like, "What did you put in this?
It tastes amazing."
So we know that our tongue
is getting it wrong,
or you might be touching something
and you look at the tag to
see what sort of textile
was used in this really
amazing piece of clothing
that you're looking to buy.
So we know that our sense of touch
isn't quite getting it right.
But rarely do we have that experience
of having our eyes get updated,
where we're looking at something,
"Oh, I think I'm looking at my mom.
Oh, no, actually, it was
actually my husband."
Okay, that never happens,
[laughing] right?
That we have gotten vision as wrong
as we might get any other thing
that we're experiencing
through any other sense.
We trust our visual experience,
we have a sort of a naive realism
that what we see reflects the
world the way it actually is,
because it's never really fully tested,
we never get the input or the feedback
that you've seen something wrong,
until a visual illusion pops
up on social media, right?
Like the dress example,
or the last week or so,
there's been that horse-seal-lion drawing
that's been all over social
media too, "What do you see?"
"I see a horse," someone
says, "I see a seal,"
and then chaos erupts,
or, "I thought the dress was blue,"
"No, I thought it was gold."
I don't remember the options
'cause I see it as blue,
so, [laughing] right?
[Andrew laughing]
And it's dividing up
families and friendships
because you've seen something
that the other person
just literally cannot see.
And that's why we love those examples
when they pop up in
social media when they do,
is because it defies all of
our previous expectations.
If this interests you,
there's a really amazing
visual artist, Anish Kapoor,
who plays with these ideas too,
and his installations
are just fascinating.
I saw one at a museum once,
where I walked down this long hall
and it's just a big black rectangle
that's painted on the wall.
And I was like, "This guy's
super famous, what the hell?
It's just a big black
rectangle painted on the wall.
What is this about,
what a hoax? [laughing]
This museum paid how
much, what?" or whatever.
But then as you get
closer, you get closer,
and your eyes start to settle in
and they adapt to the
different visual lighting,
you realize it's not a black
square painted on the wall,
it's a huge hole he's
carved into the wall,
and there is a whole other world
that's back behind there that
you can't see right away,
until your eyes adapt to the
different lighting conditions.
- Beautiful.
- It's amazing,
yeah.
- As a vision scientist,
I have to see, where is this exhibit?
- It's not up right now,
there was a retrospective
several years ago
that was done in Sydney,
but his work is all over the place.
- Great.
- So Anish Kapoor,
definitely worth looking up,
because, like the dress example,
or the horse-seal-lion drawing,
or artists like Anish Kapoor's work,
that is a moment that gives us
a different unexpected
insight about the world.
That it challenges us to see something
that we hadn't seen before,
or it induces, or tricks
us into seeing something
that we wouldn't have otherwise have seen.
And so it's those rare moments
that I think are actually really important
for understanding what
do our eyes normally do?
Because we wouldn't find
these examples so surprising,
so engaging, so shocking,
if we had routinely gotten the experience
of realizing we're not seeing
the world the way that it is.
So that is why I think vision is special,
and why it can be thought of as a tool
that we can add to our toolkit
for how to better accomplish our goals.
I'm not saying that we
should just only focus on
imagining the world through
an attentional spotlight,
but maybe that's something that
we can employ strategically
on occasion when we think
it's going to best help us,
when we need an extra little push to cross
that literal or metaphorical finish line,
but it doesn't have to be
the only tactic that we use,
just like it's not bad
to use vision boards,
but let's use something else also.
It's not bad to talk to
ourselves in encouraging ways,
but let's try adding another
tool to our tool belt
in case that's not enough
to get the job done.
So I do think that there's great power
in thinking about our visual experience
alongside other tactics that we might use
for meeting our goals.
And another one of those tactics
might be like the numerics
that you're talking about,
"Do I think about my jumping
jacks in terms of groups of 10
or as a set of 100?"
You do it routinely,
so you might be able to set a goal of 100
and have that sustain you
through number 60, number 70,
when maybe it's starting to get harder,
but for somebody who's just starting out
and wants to be able to make it to 100,
that's probably not going to work,
that could be quite challenging for them
if it's the first time
that they're trying it.
And so instead, setting those
micro goals of groups of 10
is going to be useful,
because as we start to get
to number eight or nine,
or number 88 or 89, and
it's really getting hard,
we need that extra little hedonic hit
of pleasure of accomplishment,
the micro dopamine rush
that you might get by hitting
another decade milestone,
another group-of-10 milestone.
And once we get that
little hit of pleasure,
excitement or self-congratulations,
that might be enough to sustain us
through the next challenging
physical obstacle,
the next group of 10
that we might experience.
So there isn't any
prescription that I would give
and say, "Every person should decide
that 25 jumping jacks is the goal."
No, we have to be idiosyncratic
and introspect about, "Where
are we at with this goal,
this thing that I'm trying to accomplish?"
and set those goals realistically,
but inspirationally as well.
We want to set a goal
that will challenge us,
but isn't impossible.
We don't want to set
goals that are too easy,
because we're not going to trick ourselves
into feeling so great about
doing one jumping jack, okay?
Great, I'm pretty sure most people,
if that's a goal, they can do one,
so are you going to feel so
great when you hit that goal?
No, because it was too easy,
you didn't have any doubt
that you could do that one,
but what about 25?
Okay, yeah, I might feel
pretty good about that.
Well, what about the next group of 25
and now I'm at 50?
Those are goals that might seem
just beyond the brink of what's possible,
but I will feel good when I hit that,
and that's going to give me the
next sort of boost of energy
that I'm going to need to
go a little bit further,
either that time or the next time.
- Yeah, I think vision is special,
again, I'm strongly biased here.
The reason I initially
learned about your work was,
well, now you have this amazing book,
but at the time, there wasn't the book,
there were just the scientific papers,
and of course, upon which the book rests,
and those papers are really important,
but was the relationship between vision
and obviously is our sense of space,
but how the sense of space
and time are related.
And to make the idea quite
simple for those listening,
when you narrow your visual
window, you're measuring,
the time bin also gets smaller, right?
Which makes sense when you hear it,
whereas if you take on
a huge visual landscape,
you're actually carving
up time differently.
It's sort of like moving
from a slow frame rate
to a fine frame rate,
slow-motion camera is actually taking
a lot more snapshots, right?
So you're measuring distance
over time more finely.
And so, whereas strobe
would be the other example,
which a strobe is very low frequency,
so you're going here, here, here,
as opposed to slow motion, right?
Strobe gives a course
view into the time domain
and high-speed photography
gives a fine view
into the time domain.
So I'm almost certain,
without any knowledge of underlying data,
but knowledge of the mechanism,
that I'm almost certain, if not certain,
that by placing a narrow visual aperture,
we change the way we perceive time.
Now, I have a question, and to be honest,
I know the answer in advance,
but I'd love for you to tell us
a bit about how some of this
works still further in reverse,
meaning how unfit people view the world
versus how fit people view the world,
or how unmotivated people
visually see the world,
as opposed to highly motivated people.
You talked about these elite runners,
you gave them Michael Phelps's example,
but maybe you could describe that study,
I think it's a particularly important one,
mostly because, yes, it identifies
perhaps the physiological
or psychological differences
between motivated and unmotivated,
or fit and unfit people,
but it also provides
a path to remedy that.
- Mm-hmm, yeah, out of my lab,
but also out of several other labs,
there's been work looking at that relation
between states of the body
and visual experiences.
They haven't necessarily
tried to integrate
the motivation science element to it,
but they were looking to see
do visual experiences change
as a function of different
states of our body?
So they've looked at people
who experience chronic fatigue,
the elderly, people who are overweight,
those that are wearing heavy backpacks,
and so who are sort of
put into that experience
of being overweight,
what happens to their
perceptions of the environment?
Well, what they find is
that distances look further
to those that are overweight,
chronically tired,
older rather than younger,
weighted down with extra baggage,
distances look farther
and hills look steeper.
We've done some of those studies too,
where we try to give people more energy,
or deprive them of energy,
and see does that change
their perception of space.
And we did that by sort
of a classic technique
of a double-blind study
where the participant doesn't really know
what they're experiencing.
- I thought you were going
to say, "A double espresso."
- Oh. [laughing]
That is also a good psychological
experience to give people.
Yeah, so a double-blind experiment
where the participant doesn't
really know the full extent
of what they're doing or
what they're experiencing,
and the researcher who's
interacting with them also doesn't.
They do this a lot in medical studies,
you give somebody a drug
and you give somebody a
placebo, a sugar pill,
and then importantly, nobody really knows
who's got what until you've
analyzed all the data
and the results are revealed
that these are the
people that had the drug,
the active agent,
same idea in the psychological research.
In this case, what we did was
give people Kool-Aid to drink.
And for some people, that
Kool-Aid was sweetened with sugar,
an actual caloric entity,
it could give them energy.
Other people drank Kool-Aid
sweetened with Splenda.
So, yeah, it's sweet,
but it actually doesn't
have any caloric value,
you're not giving people energy,
you're just giving them that
experience of sweetness.
Now, some people, of course,
are really good at identifying
what's real sugar and what's Splenda,
but when you put it into
Kool-Aid, a pretty noxious powder,
it actually masked it for everybody
and nobody had any idea.
- 'Cause it tasted like garbage
to everybody.
- It tastes like garbage,
yeah. [laughing]
- Sorry, Kool-Aid.
I mean, I'm sure there are
many people that love Kool-Aid,
I guess the sales of Kool-Aid
will reveal the data.
- [laughing] Yeah, I grew
up in Nebraska actually,
where Kool-Aid is from,
it originated in Nebraska.
- Oh.
- So I do feel like I'm
betraying my roots slightly
by casting some shade on Kool-Aid,
but that's how it worked,
is that we asked them
to guess what they got,
we tested them afterwards
and they were wrong.
So nobody's able to guess with accuracy,
"What was your drink sweetened with?"
Which is important
because they were blind,
the way that scientists use it,
they didn't know what it
was that they were drinking.
We give them about 10 to 15 minutes
for that sugar to metabolize,
and we measured their
circulating blood glucose levels
to make sure that we had, in fact,
given their body circulating glucose,
energy that they might
use in the next activity.
And the researcher, again,
didn't know whether they had
just served sugar or Splenda,
then we asked people to estimate distance.
So we gave some people more energy,
or we kept others sort of at
whatever their normal level was,
and what we found is that those people
who didn't even know it
but who had been given more energy
by drinking Kool-Aid sweetened with sugar,
perceived their space as more constricted,
that visual illusion of
proximity was induced,
they felt that their finish line,
again, in the context of an exercise task,
was closer to them.
So in just the same way that
these other physiology labs,
vision science, physiology labs,
found that people who
are chronically tired,
who don't feel like they
have as much energy,
or those that are physically weighted down
and for whom moving within an
environment is more costly,
we could create that
experience for people.
We did an experimental version of that,
that if you have more energy,
the world looks easier,
the distances to a finish
line don't look as far.
So that was some of the
experimental evidence that we had
to show that people's states of their body
do impact their visual experience.
Now, I'm a motivation researcher,
so for me, the big question is,
well, what's the point of that study then,
besides just showing this
connection between the body
and the eyes and the visual experience?
We think that that's fundamental
to one of the reasons
that people experience difficulty
when they're exercising,
when it's really harder for your body,
because of its physical
state, to move within a space,
you might say like, "Well, why
don't they just go exercise?"
Because the world looks harder to them,
because that distance that
they're supposed to walk
because a doctor tells them to,
or that a partner encourages them to,
or a hill that they should hike up
because someone told them
that would be good for their health,
it looks more challenging to them
than it does to somebody who's
in better physical health.
Now, if it looks that
way, if it looks harder,
if it feels like it might be harder,
then psychologically, we know that it is.
When you have set yourself
up, psychologically, mentally,
for that kind of failure experience,
like, "I don't know that
I have the resources
to get this job, this looks really hard,"
you're already motivationally in a place
for this task to be closer
to impossible for you.
So to put it all together then,
what we know is that people whose bodies
might make it more challenging
for them to exercise
are seeing the world in
a more challenging way
and that is having these
downstream motivational
and psychological effects
that makes it less likely for them
to try to take on the
task in the first place
or to experience it as harder
than other people would or do.
- Is the solution the same, however?
Meaning, if these people are taught
to adjust their visual goal line
or to set a visual spotlight
on an intermediate goal,
can they overcome some of
this challenge that they face
simply by virtue of
their skewed perception?
- Yes, so in all of the
studies that we have done,
looking at that connection
between this narrowed focus of attention
and improvements in exercise,
we do not find that it only works
for the people who are in shape
or that it backfires for
people who are out of shape,
it works for everybody.
This is a strategy that
everybody can adopt,
because it's just simply about like,
"What do you allocate
attentional resources to?
What do you sort of ignore,
and what do you focus on?"
And that visually induces
the same kind of illusion for everybody,
regardless of whether you're overweight,
or you're at your target weight,
or if you're struggling to get there,
or you've already accomplished
where you want to be,
that visual illusion can
be induced for everybody
and it has the same kinds of consequences.
- Terrific, earlier I made a
joke about double espresso,
but now I'll make a serious
statement about double espresso,
which is that it contains caffeine
and caffeine as a stimulant,
like all other stimulants,
cause a change in our visual world.
The most salient one
is the one that police officers look for,
or parents suspecting that their kids
have ingested substances
of any kind look for,
which is if somebody's
pupils are unusually large
for a given visual environment,
that is an indication of high
levels of autonomic arousal.
In the street drug translation of this,
people who take amphetamine or cocaine
will have very big pupils.
People who are very
relaxed have small pupils.
However, everyone should
know that pupil size
also is dynamically regulated
by how bright a visual environment,
so there are multiple things
controlling pupil size.
However, we know that
when we are very stressed
or very aroused in any
way, positive or negative,
the pupils get big,
but within the visual system,
what that equates to is a
narrowing of the visual aperture.
So rather than ingesting sugar,
which I'm guessing most of the world,
certainly the US needs
to ingest less sugar,
at least that's what we're hearing.
I'm sure there are a few
sugar sucro-nistas out there,
sucrose-anistas.
[Emily laughing]
Who will also come after
me with pitchforks,
but let's face it, most people
will probably be better off
ingesting less simple sugar,
but caffeine is a great motivator
because of the internal sense of arousal,
but it also narrows our visual window.
I could imagine using
healthy amounts of caffeine
combined with maybe even blinders
of the sort that horses wear,
maybe like a hoodie and a hat.
[Emily laughing]
Maybe even blinders in order to get over
some of those more challenging milestones.
Is there any evidence that
people are doing this without,
well, obviously people are doing it
without knowledge of how it works,
but are there any studies
looking at how adrenaline,
or epinephrine, or any other
stimulants impact motivation?
- I don't know, honestly, yeah.
- [Andrew] And energy
drinks are a big thing now.
- Yeah, yeah, for sure, they are,
and if you actually are more
physiologically aroused,
or jazzed, or whatever, amped up,
or you just think you are, in our studies,
we have found that they
work in the same way,
that it can produce the
same kinds of consequences.
And I like that because it tells us
you can actually change
the state of your body
to induce these kinds of experiences,
or you can just think that, [laughing]
you can trick yourself,
you can placebo effect yourself out
and produce the same kinds of effects.
I had to give up coffee like 12 years ago,
and not for any.
- I'm so sorry.
- I love the taste, [laughing]
and so decaf is my jam,
but I can't drink the caffeine,
because it didn't actually do the thing
that it does for so many other people,
like make me feel more
energized and more awake,
I just got sweaty and jittery
and anxious and I couldn't focus.
- Yeah, some people
who already have a fairly
high baseline level
of attention and motivation,
they find that it puts
the autonomic seesaw
too far in the sympathetic tone.
- Yeah.
- And I happened to marry
the same kind of person,
he also can't drink caffeine,
but loves the taste of coffee.
The interesting thing is that
we both have to have coffee
in the morning to feel like
we're ready to go for the day.
So it's just part of our
routine [laughing] or whatever,
to have that taste and have that sensation
to feel like I'm ready to take on the day,
even though, I mean, yeah,
decaf still has some caffeine in it,
but we're not drinking that much of it
to probably actually create
a caffeinated experience in our body,
but we're tricking
ourselves psychologically
into doing that thing that,
in years past, used to work for us both.
So I think that's
something to keep in mind,
like you might have a
hoodie that you can wear
to induce that visual illusion,
or you can take advantage
of the power of your mind.
At the end of the day, I'm a psychologist,
and I believe that we
have some non-zero power
over what our mind is doing,
what we're thinking about,
what we allocate our attention to,
that can do the same kind of
thing that a hoodie might do
or that a cup of caffeine might do.
- Mm-hmm, I completely agree,
the visual aperture is
under our conscious control.
That's an amazing feature
of our visual system,
we can narrow or expand it.
Takes a little bit of practice, I think,
for people to learn how to do this
without moving their head around
to expand their visual
aperture and how to narrow it,
but what I always tell people is,
"Just imagine a really
troubling text message
or a really exciting
text message coming in,
all of a sudden, you forget
about the world around you."
So it can be triggered
by these outside events
and we can learn how to
anchor our visual attention.
I'd love to ask about
other kinds of goals,
meaning non-physical goals,
because many people are trying
to read more, I would hope,
or learn music, or a language,
or things that really
involve cognitive goal lines
or internal goal lines.
Reading one chapter out
of a book each night
is a tangible goal,
the other that I've often
wondered about are these systems
that allow you to
highlight individual lines
or even words on a page,
that's very visual obviously,
and everything else is
ruled out except that word,
I've always wished for books
that would naturally highlight each page.
And as I say that, someone
will put in the comments,
this has probably existed for 10 years.
[Emily laughing]
And I'm just showing
what Luddite I am,
but is there any example or
tactic that people could use
to better approach cognitive goals,
of school, work, recreational too,
but that don't exist
in the kind of fitness and sports domain?
- Totally, yeah, so just to
shout out to my brother-in-law,
who has done some of that research,
where it does highlight
different parts of words in paragraphs,
and he's found it to be an effective way
for English-as-a-second-language
learners to pick it up,
that that is, that tying that vision
to the process of learning
language is effective.
And so there's a whole cool body of work
and researchers looking at that,
so you're right about that.
- If you want to mention what he does,
is there a place that people
can learn more about that?
We can provide links if.
- Yeah, let me.
Yeah, yeah. [laughing]
- Okay, we will provide links
to those resources,
'cause I want those resources.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I've been trying to
learn a second language
for a long time.
- Yeah, cool.
- I speak Spanish pretty weakly,
but I would love to get better at it.
- Oh, yeah.
- Okay, I'll approach you
later about that.
- My five-year-old son
speaks Spanish better
than I do at this point,
so yeah. [laughing]
- And clearly,
better than I do too,
thank you. [laughing]
- Yeah, yeah,
yeah, so I was thinking that too,
we started this work within
the context of exercise,
but of course, that's
not people's only goal
that they have in life,
and it isn't mine either,
I have interests outside of
improving my exercise game.
A couple years ago, when
I was writing the book,
I also had a child,
the same month that I had the opportunity
to pull all this research together
is the same month that my son came to be.
And I started to realize
I became a lot less
interesting once he was around,
he was fascinating,
but I was changing diapers and feeding him
and that was it.
People would come over,
be like, "What's up?
How have you been?
Tell me something that's
going on in your life,"
and all I had to talk
about was what was boring?
And I just felt like, "I've lost myself,"
I used to pride myself on crazy adventures
and problems I would get myself in
and I was a great storyteller,
and that, all of a sudden, disappeared
as soon as he came into the world,
because he became my world.
So then I started thinking, like,
"I need to pull back some coolness,
if I ever had it in the first place,
but I need to be a cooler person
than I'm coming across right now,"
so I decided, "I want
to learn to play drums,
and I want to be a one-hit
wonder as a rockstar drummer.
I only want one song,
'cause I know I'm not going to
be able to do more than that."
I'm not coordinated at all,
from the beginning of time,
in fifth grade, I have this
really vivid flash bulb memory
of playing basketball
for the very first time,
I lost my footing, I knocked
into my own teammate,
pushed her out of bounds
while she had the ball,
we lost the game and
I was not invited back
[laughing] on the team
for the next season.
And so that fomented my
self-definition of uncoordinated.
I am a musician, but I am not a drummer,
and the idea of coordinating
four limbs in real time
was like, "If I could do
that, I would be so proud."
So that's a goal that I set for myself,
at the same time that my
son came into this world,
when I was also trying to
think about goal setting
and how to improve my ability
and all of our ability to get a job done
when you're faced with
some pretty big obstacles.
So I got to practice all these techniques
that we're talking about on
myself and see for myself,
when I tell people, "Hey, try this thing,
narrowed focus of attention,
does it help with something
like becoming a better drummer?"
And the answer is yeah,
these tactics at least work for me,
sometimes, under some circumstances,
and they do for other people who try them
for other goals that aren't
necessarily about exercise.
One that I found particularly helpful
was overcoming my bad memory,
that everybody's memories
are faulty, right?
Everybody has sort of a
warped perception of the past,
it might be skewed more
positively than maybe we deserve,
or it might be skewed more negatively
if you feel that what
looms large in your mind,
as you reflect on something from the past,
or the mistakes that you've made,
or the social faux pas that you had,
or challenges that you faced at work
when you got in trouble with
a boss or with a colleague,
if that's what really
stands out in your mind,
or the good side of all
of those possibilities,
we probably aren't
getting the world right.
And that is something that
our brain has evolved,
to give us a faulty memory,
to level and sharpen, to
not encode and remember
and be able to recall everything
that we've experienced
with accuracy and precision.
And that's a problem
when it comes to assessing
our own goal progress.
When we want to be our own accountant
and try to determine, "How are we doing?
If I want to become a drummer,
am I on track for getting there before X,
before my time runs out?
Am I going to make it or not?"
And I think that's an experience,
whether they want to be a drummer or not,
that a lot of people can resonate with,
of trying to determine,
"Is this trajectory,
is this rate of progress
going to get the job done
by X amount of time?
Will I have my swimsuit body by summer?"
Or, "Will I save enough for retirement
by the time I hit 65?"
For these goals where time is involved
and there is a deadline,
we do take moments to
assess our trajectory.
And if we just rely on our memory,
we're probably going to do a bad job
of assessing that trajectory,
of knowing whether we're on pace
to meeting our deadline.
And I found that to be the
case as I was thinking about,
"Am I actually going to be
able to learn this song?
I mean, I know that
it's going a lot slower
than it probably would for anybody else,
but to give myself a
deadline and a commitment."
I decided I was going to put on a show,
I was going to invite everybody I knew
and also people I didn't know,
and I was going to play
my one song for them, so.
- This was while writing a book
and having just had a child.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So when you read the book,
you'll see my story,
and it's the real truth of it.
I mean, I did play that
show and it was fine.
And then, because I wrote
about it in the book,
then some other opportunities
to play it publicly have come up.
And it's like, "All right, I
told people I can play drums,
I better show them
that I actually still can play this song."
- [Andrew] I love it.
- Yeah, so that that's been fun.
I have become a one-hit wonder,
if you ask me to play
the song, like, "Encore,"
it's just going to get that
same song a second time,
so literally one-hit wonder.
But so in the process of figuring out,
"Am I going to be able to play this show?
I sent out invitations,
the date is committed,
people are coming to
listen to my one song,
God bless them, how's it going to go?"
And it felt awful, it just felt like,
"I am not making progress here,"
because there's a lot more things
that actually are pressing, right?
Like the kid does need to get fed,
I do have to go to my day job,
the editor is asking for
the next draft of this book,
and that is going to take precedence,
like it does for so many people,
that things command your bandwidth,
even when you have this goal
that you've committed to
and that you've got on the books.
And so I just felt this looming anxiety
about this goal that would require,
didn't have to be daily practice,
but you can't cram that kind of a goal,
it does take committed investment
for a sustained period of time.
And so I had this looming anxiety
that I'm not making good enough progress,
but that's because I
was relying on my memory
and my brain to recall, like,
"How many times did you practice?
What was it like the
last time you practiced?
What was it like when you
tried to play this bit
or this riff like two weeks ago,
have you gotten any better since then?"
And it just felt like, "No,
I haven't practiced enough.
I don't remember when the
last time I played was,
but it definitely doesn't feel
like I'm getting any better."
Then I thought, "You know what?
I should stop relying
on my brain to tell me,
where am I at and am I
on an upward slope here?
I need to look at the data."
I love data, scientists love data,
so I started to collect data on myself.
What I did was download this app
that a friend had told me
about called the Reporter App,
there's lots of these
kinds of things out there.
Basically, it just sets up your phone
to randomly ping you
with whatever questions
you want your phone to ask.
It records your answers,
you can download the data,
you can make pretty graphs
to see, "What's my change
and how I've answered
these questions over time?"
So I did that for a month,
for a month, I had my phone
ask me a couple of times a day,
well, maybe twice a day
really, "Did you practice,
since last time I asked
you," my phone says,
"did you practice?"
Mostly it was no,
and if yes, then it would funnel
a couple of other questions,
like, "How did you do, how do you feel?
Check a couple of
different emotion words now
about your experience when you played."
And I did that for a month,
after a month, went into my
office, downloaded the data,
and first took stock before
I looked at the numbers,
like, "How do I think I
did over the last month?"
And I thought, "Same as every other month,
I didn't really get anywhere.
Yeah, I practiced, but
I still feel awful."
And I cried, I cried having to practice.
I was upset with myself
for setting this goal
and feeling so anxious about it.
All I remember is that I cried,
cried too much about
this personal conquest
that wouldn't matter to anybody else.
Honestly, it really doesn't matter
in the scope of things anyway,
I'm not going to become
a drummer professionally,
so who cares if I
embarrass myself publicly?
But what I found from the data
was my memory was totally wrong,
I actually had practiced far
more times than I remembered,
and when I looked at my
emotion words that I used,
it was a clear upward trajectory.
Yeah, I did cry,
that part I hadn't
misremembered or made up,
but by the end of that month,
I had gotten a compliment from my husband,
who actually is a drummer,
and said like, "Hey,
that wasn't that bad."
And then there was one expletive,
"You were effing amazing [laughing]
at that one thing you'd
been practicing at."
But like, "Okay, fine, he's my
husband, right, is he just?"
So at the moment, it didn't
really feel that great,
and I downplayed it, and as a result,
it didn't stick in my brain, right?
I remember how stupid it felt that I cried
because I can't make progress,
and I downplayed in my mind
the thing that actually should've been
a legitimate indicator that
progress was being made.
So all of which is to say,
I needed to collect that data on myself
and to look at it objectively,
accurately and completely,
because my brain wasn't doing that for me.
That visual experience [laughing]
of downloading that data
and looking at what was
my actual experience
gave me better insight
as I was trying to assess the
trajectory of my progress,
I became a more accurate
accountant of my own progress,
which is important for setting goals
or resetting them when
you need to calibrate
in light of what's left to do
and how much time do you have to do it in?
- I love it, so basically,
if I understand correctly,
when the intermediate goals
of say daily practice,
or twice-a-day practice,
or reading, or math, et cetera,
are not a visual goal line,
it really does help to visualize
some aspect related to
that non-visual goal line,
in this case, the Reporter
App was a useful tool.
I've never heard of it, I plan to use it,
I'm sure a number of people
will be interested in it,
sounds like there are others out there,
but that's the one that
you found most useful?
- Yeah, yeah, there's another one too
that is even more visual than that,
[laughing] than the Reporter App,
although that has visual components
and is really effective if you like data
and want to collect numbers on
yourself or your experience,
there's another one called
the 1 Second Everyday app.
This is really awesome
because the app is a mechanism
to record one second of your life.
There's such an awesome
community of people
that just live by this and
love having these experiences,
and the creator of it I got
to a chance to talk with,
and he has done this,
he's taken a one-second video
of some aspect of his life,
every day, for, I don't know, 12 years,
13 years or something.
- One second?
- Yeah, one second.
And then what the app
does is smash 'em together
and give you a chronology
of what your year,
or your month, or your last
decade of life has been like,
and presents it as like a
streamlined video for you.
So you just see these flashes
of your life over however
long you tell the app
to create a montage for you.
And so when you see these
videos that people have made,
especially those that have been doing it
for a really long time, it's fascinating.
I did that for myself too, I tried it,
one second of today's drumming
performance, another second,
it's not enough to capture,
"Am I actually doing a
good job of drumming?"
or, "What's my trajectory for drumming?"
But the guy who made it says
one of the most awesome one-second
videos that he ever made
is of a brick wall.
I was like, "Well, you
didn't need a video of that,
what's the wall doing?"
It's not crumbling,
it's not in earthquake land
or something like that,
it's just slightly jittery,
one second of a brick wall.
And I was like, "How is that motivating
or exciting to you, why is that?
You've been doing this for 13
years every day, one second,
why is that the one second
that matters to you most?"
And he says, "Because when
it comes up in my montage,
it reminds me of a really
horrific moment in my family.
That was the first wall that I saw
when I walked out of the room
having heard that my sister-in-law
had this awful, awful experience,
her intestines started
to twist up on themselves
and knot up,
and she was on the brink of death.
And we had just found this out,
she had just gotten into the hospital,
they diagnosed this issue that
required immediate surgery.
And our family was there
to hear about this,
and we were all stunned
that she might die,
like, 'Right now, she might die.'
And that's the first thing that I saw,
and it reminds me of how precious life is,
how important family is
and how the rest of whatever
we were doing that day didn't matter,
because we all needed to be
here together right now."
And that is all of this
emotion and purpose in life
is conjured up or reminded
when he looks at one
second of a brick wall
as it pops into his video feed.
So if you're visually oriented
and you do want ways to remember,
"What was life like,
what has my year in review,
what does it look like?"
that's an awesome app, 1 second Everyday,
that can help you do that.
- These are great recommendations.
And a couple of reflections,
first of all, the brick wall example
is a beautiful way of highlighting
this other feature of the visual system,
which is that the brain
largely thinks in symbols,
it's very efficient,
it batches entire
experiences into symbols,
and in this case, the brick wall
can be attached to a
whole set of experiences
that are very meaningful
to this individual,
that brick walls don't mean that,
or didn't mean that to
me until hearing this.
So I think that it highlights
the fact that the actual
symbol is less relevant
than what we attach to that symbol,
but that symbols are so efficient
that even in a one-second
view of something,
we can attach to it,
for better or for worse.
The other is that I'm a
absolute, almost rabid proponent
of people getting morning
sunlight in their eyes
as the fundamental layer of
setting their circadian rhythms
and sleep and health as
a zero-cost practice,
that believe it or not, can be done
any time of year, or anywhere.
[Emily laughing]
But it does take a little bit of effort,
you have to get outside,
you can't do it through a window
or a windshield for it to be efficient,
but it has huge outsize
effects on human health,
this has now been demonstrated
again and again and again.
And so I'm going to just do
a sort of call to action,
if people aren't already doing this,
I'm going to start using the 1 Second app
to record my morning sunlight viewing,
and prove that even through cloud cover,
you're getting more photons
than you are indoors
and that it's worthwhile.
I also would love to do
this for my next dog,
to go from puppy to full-size dog,
and maybe even to the end, who knows?
Great, these are wonderful tools,
you've given us a huge
number of practical tools,
which, frankly, isn't always
the case on these podcasts.
We always strive to do science
and science-based tools
as our kind of mantra,
but you've given a rich
set of tools here to apply.
I just want to briefly
backtrack to something,
and then a final question.
Earlier, we were talking
about how unfit people
see the world as more challenging,
maybe even hills as steeper,
distances as further,
and how shifting people
into a state of energy,
either cognitively or through
the ingestion of real glucose
to get an energetic lift,
or maybe through caffeine
if that's within their practice
and span of healthy
behaviors, they could do that.
There's so many people who
are suffering from depression,
which one of the key
features of depression
is a lack of energy,
even though there can be an anxiety
associated with depression,
I have to wonder whether
or not some of these tools
are being deployed or will be deployed
in the context of mental health,
because depression is
this vicious loop, right?
People feel a lack of
energy and hopelessness,
and then things just look harder,
and so then it just verifies
their negative worldview
and it's a downward spiral.
That's why medication, in some cases,
and social sport, et
cetera, can be helpful,
because they feel more energized,
the side effects, often,
are a problem, however.
Have there been any efforts to implement
some of these visual tools
to create this increase
in systolic blood pressure
and a kind of readiness and willingness
to lean into what people
perceive as immense challenge?
And if not, for anyone listening,
I know we have a lot of listeners
in the mental health space
and in the helping space, so to speak,
I can imagine these are zero cost, right?
We all provide, with
people that are sighted,
have the apparati to do it.
Are you aware of any studies like this
or is your laboratory
involved in any studies?
'Cause I just see an immense value
of implementing the sorts of
tools that you've developed.
- Yeah, we haven't explored
those ideas directly.
So call to all the scientists
that are out there,
there's a great opportunity to
start looking at these tools
within the mental health
space, you're right.
Other researchers though have,
not this use of inducing a
narrowed attentional focus
and can they now feel more
energized to go for a run?
But they have looked at the
relationship between anxiety,
depression and visual experience,
and found, over decades,
evidence that people with
depression or with anxiety,
what their attention is captured by
within the bigger global surrounding world
are those things that are negative
or reinforcing of their worldview.
Now, that happens for everybody,
that things that are on our
mind tend to pop out, [laughing]
that whatever we're thinking about,
we might start seeing some version of it
showing up in the world around us
that captures our attention.
That's an idea called priming,
what we're thinking
about might then lead us
to attend to the world,
to see things in a way that aligns
with what we're already thinking about,
it's just that when what
we're thinking about
are those depressive, ruminative,
anxiety, fearful thoughts,
when that is what is
cognitively accessible,
when that's what's going through our mind,
then that's also what
captures our visual gaze.
So when we think like, "The world is hard,
the world is full of sadness,"
and that's the thought in our mind,
and then we start seeing the people
with frowns on their faces
or who are experiencing anxiety,
and that's what captures our attention,
even when there's other people around
that might not be seeing the world
or experiencing the world that way,
it becomes reinforcing.
When I think that the
world is threatening,
and then I notice the
threats that are around me,
that confirms what I'm thinking,
which heightens my anxiety or my fear,
and then it further leads me
to narrowly focus on those
elements of the environment
that are aligned with that worldview,
it's really hard to get out of that,
that's where the vicious
cycle can come from.
So that has been really well established
within the medical community,
this selective attention
relating to states of mental unwellness,
that's been pretty well established.
And so there's been
some interventions done
with people that have
depression or anxiety,
saying like, "Here's an array,
a photograph of a bunch
of different faces.
Yes, it's artificial,
it kind of looks like
a page from a yearbook,
a high school yearbook,
but look for the faces that are smiling,
look at the faces that are smiling.
Try right now, spend 10 minutes
having your eyes focus on those
and look at those people,"
that it is an effective intervention
at improving [sighing] people's
sense of self-efficacy,
of, "What can I accomplish next?"
They feel a little bit more energized.
It doesn't cure depression,
it doesn't cure anxiety.
I mean, these are literal
physical afflictions that we have,
so it's not a quick fix,
but it can produce a temporary change
that might be a way to start
getting out of that rut.
- Mm-hmm, yeah, and I think nowadays
there's an increasing attention on tools
that will help people orient
as they start to veer
towards suicidal depression,
or veer back into a depressive
episode, or anxiety episode.
I mean, trying to reverse
an entire syndrome
or set of syndromes is
far more complicated.
Likewise, in the health space,
just trying to get people
to deploy realtime tools
to adjust their anxiety or to
exercise more often and so on.
As a kind of a final,
but also kind of a high-level question,
I'm imagining that,
and I plan to use this visual
goal setting of spotlighting,
I've been using it actually
for some time on runs,
it works really well.
Yesterday, I took a run
near the waterfront here,
and I think I did it somewhat incorrectly,
the entire run, I was thinking about
getting back to the statue,
at which I started.
- [laughing] Yeah.
- But I did find that I ran
fastest in the final 20 meters.
- Cool.
- Which, admittedly,
wasn't fast at all,
but it was faster than what preceded it.
[Emily laughing]
So it works and it makes perfect
sense as to how it works.
You've done other studies
exploring some of the
other features of vision,
like the luminosity,
how bright something is
and how people perceive it.
That was in a completely
different context,
but is there a kind of a higher level,
a kind of a black belt version
of what we're talking about here,
where not only am I focusing
on a specific visual location
as an intermediate or a long-term goal,
or I'm using an app to ask me a question
and tap into how I'm feeling,
create a visual representation
of my motivational state,
but that I'm also making my
phone as bright as possible,
I'm also trying to take that visual window
and actually pay attention
to more of the details
at that location?
Or is it simply a matter of kind of,
in geek speak, visual neuroscience,
we would just call this
like low spatial frequency,
just sort of grabbing a
black and white snapshot
of something here or there in my mind?
If I attach more detail and
effort to the specific thing
that I'm focused on,
is there any evidence that
that's more effective?
- It certainly changes what our
brains are doing, [laughing]
so how do we define effectiveness?
That's a question for
philosophers and that scientists
will always debate.
- Will it keep me running?
- Yeah. [laughing]
[Andrew laughing]
It will when you use it
towards the end of your run,
just like you've picked up on.
Yeah, so there's cool
studies that neuroscientists,
not I, not coming from my lab,
that neuroscientists have done
looking at, "What is
it doing to your brain
when you've decided that you're
going to focus your attention
on this element of the world
and not pay attention to something else?
Is that just sort of
tricking your thoughts
or is it doing something different,
to something more basic, more low level?"
And the answer is yes,
so there's an area of the brain,
the fusiform face area,
it's a part of our brain
that's really specialized
for making sense of faces.
It's important as a social species
to pay attention to other people,
pay attention to their faces,
what they're trying to
communicate through their face,
and so our brain has developed
a really specialized central
area for doing that then.
And so these neuroscientists
will present a face to somebody,
but superimposed over that is a house
or something else that is
less special [laughing]
to us as a social human species.
And so both of those things,
because it's sort of like both images
are sort of transparent,
overlaid over one another,
our eyes are getting
both of those images in
and our brain is getting
both of those images in,
but we can will ourselves
to focus on the house.
"Just really pay attention
to the features of the house,
even though everything about
that face is still there too,"
or, "Pay attention to the face
and just tell me, what is
it that you are deciding
that you want to hold on to,
that you want to look at right now?"
And you can see that the
brain is responding to that,
so when people are saying like,
"I'm really seeing that face,
the details of the face,
'cause I'm paying attention to the face,"
even though we know their
eyes are also looking at
and engaged with the contents of the house
that's right there, smacked on top,
the fusiform face area lights up.
And when they're saying like,
"Nah, I'm really focused
on the house now,"
we see activation in the
fusiform face area decline
and other areas of the brain's
neurological real estate
start to engage.
So yeah, I think there's something to it,
that, at a high level,
our brains are responding
to our psychology as well.
And we have that great power to really,
with intention, with practice,
decide, "How do I want to
engage with the world?"
And can it produce real
change in our bodies
and in the way that we
experience the world?
The answer is yes.
- Fantastic, well,
you've given us a ton of mechanistic
and conceptual and practical information,
so I'm speaking for a lot of people
when I say thank you for taking the time
out of your schedule,
amidst kids and running a lab
and teaching at the
university and your book,
which we will point people to
and provide a link to,
as a wonderful resource,
and we hope to have you back again.
- Thank you so much, it
was a great conversation.
- Thank you.
- Thanks.
- Thank you for joining me
today for our discussion
about motivation, goal seeking
and research-supported tools
for achieving your goals
with Dr. Emily Balcetis.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel,
that's a terrific zero-cost
way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to the podcast
on Apple and Spotify,
and on both Apple and Spotify,
you can leave us up to a five-star review.
Please leave us any
comments, or suggestions,
or ideas for future guests,
or questions about particulars
of any podcast episode
in the comment section on YouTube,
we do read all the comments.
Please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning
of today's episode,
and check out Athletic Greens,
that's the best way to
support this podcast.
In addition, please check out
our Neural Network Newsletter,
that is a zero-cost newsletter
available to anyone,
you just provide an email
and we do not share
your email with anybody,
you simply go to hubermanlab.com,
you go to the menu,
you look for the Neural
Network Newsletter.
And by signing up for the newsletter,
you can get summaries of podcast episodes,
detailed lists of protocols
related to podcast episodes,
again, all zero cost,
we don't share your information,
and if you'd like to see
examples of previous newsletters,
they are also available on
our website, hubermanlab.com.
If you're not already
following us on social media,
we are Huberman Lab on
both Twitter and Instagram.
There, I cover science
and science-related tools,
some of which overlap with the contents
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
but much of which is
distinct from the information
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
Again, it's Huberman Lab on Instagram
and Huberman Lab on Twitter.
And as mentioned at the
beginning of today's episode,
we are now partnered with
Momentous supplements,
because they make
single-ingredient formulations
that are of the absolute highest quality,
and they ship international.
If you go to livemomentous.com/huberman,
you will find many of the supplements
that have been discussed
on various episodes
of the Huberman Lab Podcast,
and you will find various protocols
related to those supplements.
So thank you once again
for joining us today
for our discussion about the science
and science-related tools of motivation,
goal seeking and pursuit,
and last but certainly not least,
thank you for your interest in science.